meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen wir heißen sie herzlich
willkommen zur pressekonferenz der
freien demokraten zum ausgang der
bundestagswahl der landtagswahl in
mecklenburg vorpommern ist und der wahl
zum berliner abgeordnetenhaus
hat der bundesvorsitzende christian
lindner ja meine damen meine herren wir
haben natürlich im präsidium und im
bundesvorstand zunächst unser eigenes
wahlergebnis bewertet wir haben ein
wahlerfolg erzielt
im vergleich zu den früheren
bundestagswahlen ist es zum ersten mal
gelungen bei zwei aufeinanderfolgenden
wahltermin zweistellig abzuschneiden die
fdp hat eines der besten ergebnisse
ihrer geschichte errungen wir haben im
wahlkampf sehr eigenständig für unsere
grundwerte geworben werden den wert der
freiheit ins zentrum gestellt wir haben
für das wirtschaftliche vorankommen
eines jeden einzelnen menschen und
unseres landes insgesamt partei
ergriffen wir haben ausgestrahlt die
neugier auf und die freude an
technologie statt einer verbots haltung
wir haben also für unsere politischen
grundwerte für unsere grundeinstellung
geworben und sind für diese auch gewählt
boden wir haben
bei den erst- und zweitstimmen eine viel
geringere unterscheidung als bei
früheren wahlen wir sind die stärkste
kraft bei den erstwählern und sind mit
denen gemeinsam bei den jungwählern
vorne wir haben jetzt die marke von
76.000 mitgliedern überschritten also
einen rekordstand bei den mitgliedern
erreicht und dazu gleich noch wir haben
bei zwei wichtigen landtagswahlen am
gestrigen tag erfolg gehabt all das
diese indikatoren zusammengenommen jung
und erstwählern splitting verhalten
rekord bei den mitgliedern zeigte 1 die
fdp ist als ein eigenständiges
politisches angebot
gestern gestärkt worden es waren die
freien demokraten die von den
wählerinnen und wählern tatsächlich
gemeint waren das war kein taktisches
wahlverhalten für uns
wir freuen uns über diesen erfolg und
wollen alles in unserer macht stehende
unternehmen um aus diesem erfolg dann
auch politische gestaltung werden zu
lassen mit großer verantwortung für die
eigenständige politisch inhaltliche
positionen die wir haben
wir haben beschlossen er erstens dass
wir
sondierungen oder vor sondierungen mit
bündnis 90/die grünen aufnehmen der
bundesvorstand hat volker wissing und
nicht damit beauftragt diese gespräche
zu führen zwischen grünen und fdp gibt
es die größten inhaltlichen
unterschiede bei den parteien des
demokratischen zentrums die jetzt über
eine regierungsbildung miteinander
sprechen könnten deshalb macht es sinn
angesichts dieser bisweilen bestehenden
polarisierung den gemeinsamen grund zu
suchen zugleich sind grüne und fdp aber
auch die parteien die sich am stärksten
gegen den status quo der großen
koalition gewarnt haben weder die union
noch die spd stehen für aufbruch beide
parteien regieren lange die spd mit vier
jahren pause seit
1998 das ist keine partei des aufbruchs
die union genauso wenig die parteien die
eine veränderung weg vom status quo
gewollt haben in den vergangenen jahren
das waren grüne und fdp und deshalb ist
es sinnvoll dass diese beiden zuerst
miteinander das gespräch suchen um zu
prüfen ob daraus bei allen unterschieden
ein
fortschrittliches zentrum einer neuen
koalition werden könnte wir haben
zweitens beschlossen dass wir
danach also nach den gesprächen mit
bündnis 90 die grünen offen sind
einladungen von cdu/csu oder spd
anzunehmen wenn sie denn kommen über
weitergehende gespräche
drittens haben wir
seitens der csu und der spd
führung
hinweise inhaltlicher art an die fdp
aufgenommen
wir haben aber entschieden dass wir uns
an dieser faszinierenden kommunikation
der spd-spitze nicht beteiligen wollen
wir wurden in den letzten monaten oft
gefragt was es bedeutet wenn die freien
demokraten
eigenständig auf einen eigenen inhalt
fokussiert und nicht taktischen eine
bundestagswahl gehen seit gestern wissen
wir
sind beauftragt gemeinsam mit anderen
die in der bundesrepublik der
bundesrepublik deutschland eine
regierung zu bilden
parteien können wahlen gewinnen oder
verlieren ende - eine regierung so
gebildet werden dass die bürgerinnen und
bürgern alle zu gewinnen werden das ist
die messlatte und der auftrag vor dem
wir stehen
wir haben gestern aber nicht nur an sehr
gutes bundestagswahlergebnis erhalten
sondern wir freuen uns riesig dass wir
auch zwei landtagswahlen erfolgreich
meistern konnten zum einen die
abgeordnetenhauswahl hier in berlin mit
sebastian czaja an der spitze
das ist keine einfache
abgeordnetenhauswahl gewesen auch hier
sind wir eigenständig mit einem klaren
profil in die landtagswahl gegangen und
sebastian czaja steht vor einer
spannenden aufgabe dem land berlin an
senat zu bilden
sehr zuversichtlich dass die fdp hier
eine ebenso konstruktive und sachliche
rolle spielen wird wie im bund das
gleiche gilt in mecklenburg vorpommern
wo wir mit rené bongartz spitzenkandidat
eine äußerst schwierige landtagswahl aus
der außerparlamentarischen opposition
führen durften und in den landtag in
schwerin einziehen konnten damit ist die
kraft der freiheit in deutschland
insgesamt gestärkt ich bin
möglicherweise
zusätzlichen einfluss im bundesrat
das wird man sehen aber auf jeden fall
ist ein weiteres bundesland mit
parlamentarischer beteiligung der freien
demokraten
vielfältiger und spannender geworden
darüber freuen wir uns sehr insgesamt
war der gestrige wahltag ein großer
erfolg für die organisierte
freiheitsbewegung in deutschland freien
demokraten gehen gestärkt aus diesem
wahlsonntag wir gehen aber auch auf die
arbeit in den nächsten monaten mit dem
mut zu die verantwortung ist groß die
aufgaben sind groß wenn man sich die
bandbreite der themen anschaut die
bewältigt werden müssen dann ist das
eine herkules aufgabe
deswegen ist es wichtig dass jeder
gesprächspartner auf jeder ebene sich
der vollen verantwortung bewusst ist ich
bin noch zur bundestagswahl abschließend
sagen dass sie wählen und wer uns keine
einfache aufgabe gegeben haben aber
dass wir mit dem fokus auf inhaltliche
schwerpunkte gut beraten sind die vor
uns liegenden gespräche zu führen und
ich bin sehr zuversichtlich dass wir das
erfolgreich machen werden in welcher
konstellation auch immer
dann würden wir direkt mit
genau dem spitzenkandidaten für die
abgeordnetenhauswahl in berlin und
landes
vielen dank meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren
christian lindner und volker wissing
haben das angesprochen wir stehen in
berlin vor
der frage einer regierungsbildung ich
darf mich zunächst bedanken auch noch
mal bei den wählerinnen und wählern die
uns hier einen vertrauenszuwachs in
berlin gegeben haben bei dieser wahl und
wir haben vor der wahl sehr klar gesagt
dass wir antreten in berlin um einen
regierungswechsel herbeizuführen
der ball liegt nunmehr bei franziska
giffey als diejenige die einen klaren
regierungsauftrag nunmehr in berlin hat
eine regierung zu bilden und wir werden
sehen ob sie sich an das hält was sie
vor der wahl in aussicht gestellt hat
einen politikwechsel umsetzen möchte und
genau für diesen politikwechsel sind wir
angetreten ein bündnis der mitte in
berlin und dieses bündnis der mitte das
kann mit den freien demokraten gelingen
der ball allerdings liegt bei ihr sie
muss entscheiden ob sie dieses bündnis
was sie den berlinerinnen und berlinern
in aussicht gestellt hat tatsächlich
bilden möchte oder ob sie ein weiter so
mit rot rot grün macht wir jedenfalls
würden in der tat mit ihr in gespräche
eintreten
und der spitzenkandidat für die ab für
die landtagswahl in mecklenburg
vorpommern
vielen dank wie christian lindner und
volker wichtigen ausgeführt hatten es
war tatsächlich ein schwerer wahlkampf
in mecklenburg vorpommern nach zehn
jahren außerparlamentarischer opposition
mit einer die stärke von fünf mitglieder
wieder einzuziehen das ist tatsächlich
eine herausforderung gewesen wir
bedanken uns bei allen wählerinnen und
wählern die uns die treue gehalten haben
über die schweren jahre das ist ja eine
teamleistung sowohl des gesamten
bundesverbandes aber eben auch eines
landesverbandes wäre natürlich
strukturell schwächer aufgestellt war
vielleicht mal als manch anderer wir
haben eine situation in mecklenburg
vorpommern nach der wahl vorfinden
können indem sich die
ministerpräsidenten die amtierende
manuela schwesig die koalitionspartner
tatsächlich aussuchen kann wir werden
sehen welche verhandlungen jetzt geführt
werden für uns ist aber erst einmal
wichtig eine fraktion aufzubauen und wie
wir das land voranbringt mecklenburg
vorpommern ist in vielen vielen punkten
weit zurück ob von der oppositionsbank
oder sogar aus einer regierung heraus
das wird sich in den nächsten tagen
zeigen wir sind zumindest
gesprächsbereit vielen dank
dank und ich habe schon die erste
fragerunde hier notierte stadt mit herrn
decker dann herr leithäuser herr rösler
aufbricht
die gespräche die sie jetzt mit den
grünen zunächst führen wollen wie weit
sollen die denn gehen soll das sagen nur
ein gespräch sein wo man sich abtastet
und x mal so informell kommt oder so
soll das soll das weitergehen und wollen
sie da möglicherweise sozusagen schon
schon erste vereinbarung möglicherweise
oder konsens herstellen mit denen sie
dann in weitere gespräche mit spd und
union gehen das ist die erste frage die
zweite frage als größtes hindernis auf
dem weg zu einer jamaika koalition
könnte sich ja armin laschet erweisen
weil es ja doch hinweise gibt dass ja in
der union keine autorität mehr hat und
auch von den grünen voraussichtlich
nicht gewählt werden
sie als langjähriger weggefährte von
herrn laschet bauen sie noch auf ihn und
können sie noch auf den bau
decker zu ihrer ersten frage
kann man zur stunde öffentlich nichts
sagen
und zu ihrer zweiten frage
personalentscheidungen anderer parteien
liegen ja außerhalb unserer
verantwortung da geben wir auch keine
ratschläge das muss jede partei für sich
selber entscheiden
dann gehen wir direktionen leithäuser
ich würde trotzdem da gerne weitermachen
herr lindner sie sagten
dass die grünen und die fdp gemeinsam
quasi ein zentrum der modernisierung
bilden könnten einer neuen regierung
wollte ich sie gerne einladen das ein
bisschen zu beschreiben was sie darunter
verstehen vielleicht auch sagt politisch
und zweitens scheint es mir so zu sein
dass in diesem zentrum der
modernisierung ist am 2 präsidenten gibt
für den posten des finanzministers
nämlich ein haar weg und sie und die
frage wäre ob sie darin ein hindernis
sehen eine zusammenarbeit oder ob das
dann auf einen dritten verlagert werden
müsste dieses ministerium einen
innerkoalitionären frieden zu bewahren
ich hatte ja eben ausgeführt dass grüne
und fdp in der sache sehr stark
polarisiert sind
sehr unterschiedliche herangehensweisen
verpflegen zu den großen
herausforderungen
wir eher ein technologisch getriebenes
modell von klimaschutz verfolgen die
grünen ist ein geradezu eine kulturelle
frage eine lebensstil frage daraus
machen das sind polarisierungen
zugleich und das ist die gemeinsamkeit
zugleich sind aber beide grüne wie fdp
eigenständig in die wahl gegangen die
grünen sogar mit dem anspruch auf das
kanzleramt
und beide haben aus der eigenständigen
position die politik von cdu/csu und spd
kritisieren haben alternativen
aufgezeigt beide grüne wie fdp wollten
weg vom status quo einer spd die seit
1998 nahezu ununterbrochen regiert und
einer union die seit
2005 die regierungsgeschäfte führt beide
union wie spd stehen für einen status
quo den grüne wie fdp
überwinden wollen und vor dem
hintergrund wollen wir prüfen
in gesprächen ob es ein
fortschrittliches zentrum geben kann aus
dieser gemeinsamen eigenständigen
haltung gegenüber dem status quo zu
ihrer zweiten frage es geht uns um
inhalte und es geht nicht um karrieren
und
wir gehen zur nächsten frage zuwenden
brössler
herr lindner sie sagten personalfragen
liegen nicht in ihre reichweite anderer
partei ist es ja nicht nur eine
personalfrage ist es ja auch die frage
der aufstellung der union wenn sie sich
heute anschauen die innerhalb der union
diskutiert wird sehen sie da
möglicherweise die situation in der sie
dann sagen müssen jamaika ist einfach
wegen des zustands der union für uns
keine option mehr und noch eine frage
wenn ich darf zum sinn und zweck und zum
ziel der gespräche mit bündnis 90 die
grünen jetzt idealerweise halten sie es
für möglich dass man zu einem
gemeinsamen zu einer gemeinsamen
empfehlung kommt welche
koalitionsoptionen wir funktionieren
kann
ich möchte über die internen beratungen
anderer parteien nicht spekulieren dazu
fehlt mir sowohl die
legitimation als auch die kenntnisse und
deshalb ist das nicht empfehlenswert und
zum anderen bitte ich sie um verständnis
dass ich über einzelheiten der geplanten
gespräche öffentlich nicht auskunft
geben kann um auch das klima des
vertrauens das erarbeitet werden muss
nicht zu gefährden
und wir haben die nächste frage von frau
emrich
herr lindner wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe ist dieses
gesprächsformat das uns alle hier so
sehr interessiert ja auch eine lehre aus
den gescheiterten jamaika verhandlungen
von 2017 den kleinen rahmen erst mal
vertrauen schaffen verstehe ich sie
richtig dass es eine vierer runde sein
wird sie sagten gerade sie und herr bis
hingehen von seiten der fdp rein dann
würde man vermuten dass auch von den
grünen zweig oder kann er sein dass er
wieder zehn leute auflaufen wie damals
vor vier jahren und die frage wie lange
wollen sie reden auch das war damals ja
so eine lehre das zieht sich ewig hin
und so weiter haben sie sich so ein sind
gesagt eine woche oder wenn wir in drei
tagen nicht zu einem ergebnis kommen ist
das schon gescheit also was ist die
zeitliche perspektive die sich dort
leben oder nehmen
ich habe mit herrn habeck noch nicht
verabredet was genau wir über den
charakter dieser gespräche öffentlich
kommunizieren wollen und deshalb will
ich die frage zur jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht beantworten
und beginnt direkt zur nächsten frage
direkt hier vorne
philipp externe die hauptstadt direkt
daran anknüpfend es gab jetzt aber schon
gespräche mit herrn harbeck weil sie
haben jetzt den fahrplan dargelegt herr
lindner erst gespräche mit den grünen
sie sprachen sogar von
regierungsverhandlungen über vor
sondierungen danach wenn man offen für
gesprächsangebote ist das jetzt ein
angebot an die grünen oder ist das
vereinbart auch mit den grünen bereits
dass man so vorgehen möchte das ist
unser
beschluss wie wir es machen das findet
ja andere parteien nicht wir haben
beschlossen dass wir erst ein gespräch
mit bündnis 90/die grünen führen und
dass wir danach offen sind falls wir von
anderen eingeladen werden mit denen dann
in weitere gespräche einzutreten wie
andere parteien das handhaben das liegt
in deren verantwortung nicht bei uns
insofern handelt sich um unseren
beschluss wie wie wir das gerne
sortieren möchten
dann haben wir es nicht kennt weil ahnt
und drauf
ja herr lindner noch einmal eine frage
wer hat es denn bereits kontakte gegeben
zur grünen spitze will ihren satz gerade
eben sie hätten sich noch nicht mit
herrn beck darauf verständigt was man
sozusagen mitteilen kann aus den
gesprächen deutet darauf hin dass sie
bereits in irgendeiner form sms oder
irgendeiner form schon miteinander
gesprochen haben vielleicht können sie
dazu was sagen das zweite im anschluss
aus dem
cdu präsidium wird berichtet herr
laschet habe gesagt er habe mit ihm
gestern nacht sehr länglich
miteinander gesprochen können sie uns
darf vielleicht sagen dass das so
stattgefunden wörter stattgefunden in
welcher form und was haben sie haben sie
haben das gut gemacht sozusagen
dabei zu bleiben vielleicht können sie
uns ein bisschen davon verraten
ich habe nach
nachdem nach der schließung der
wahllokale mit herrn laschet mit herrn
scholz und mit herrn habeck jeweils
telefoniert aber
einzelheiten aus persönlichen gesprächen
möchte ich nicht mitteilen
bitte noch mal eine nachfrage hat es
dann spät in der nacht es kolportiert
wird mit herrn laschet da noch mal einen
extra gespräch zwischen ihnen beiden
gegeben ich habe gesagt dass ich nach
schließung der wahllokale bis jetzt mit
den drei genannten
jeweils
telefoniert habe dass ich aber darüber
hinaus aus persönlichen gesprächen nicht
zu berichten beabsichtige
sie haben gesagt sie hätten mit herrn
habe telefoniert heißt dass herr haben
ist jetzt für sie bei der bei den grünen
der starke mann und nicht mehr frau
bewerbung also ist ja auch kein man aber
aber
sozusagen spielt dort jetzt habe ich die
schlüsselrolle für sie frage 1 und phase
2 ist wir kennen ja herr laschet eben
aussehen aus nordrhein westfalen aber
wie würden sie ihr verhältnis zu olaf
scholz beschreiben
herr scholz und ich sprechen offen wir
haben ja auch während der vergangenen
vier jahre aus anders etwa von
grundgesetzänderungen miteinander
gespräche geführt um
zwei drittel mehrheiten zu organisieren
bei den grünen gibt es unverändert eine
doppelspitze in der parteiführung und
ich habe keinen keinen grund zu annahmen
dass sich das ändern würde
dann haben wir die nächsten beiden
fragen oft dieser
seehofer ich bin für welt.tv wir herr
lindner eine frage zu der idee des
modernisierungsprozesses den jmstv oder
die idee die gäste ins spiel gebracht
hat was hat ihn schuldig kann es
akustisch haben okay kann es mich an
jmstv hat die idee eines modernisierungs
paktes eines gemeinsamen der beiden
parteien ins spiel gebracht was halten
sie davon
diese idee ist mir noch nicht im
einzelnen bekannt deshalb kann ich das
jetzt nicht kommentieren also weiß nicht
was er sich genau darunter vorstellt
geworden dass man sowas macht man
zunächst nur ein wort das hört sich so
an die zukunfts koalition von herrn
laschet modernisierungs pack noch ist es
ein wort was verbirgt sich dahinter das
ist ja die die frage und ich weiß jetzt
nicht was im einzelnen damit
beabsichtigt ist in der sache aber es
macht zum jetzigen zeitpunkt auch keinen
dann glaube ich weiteren sinn über
einzelne politische inhalte öffentlich
zu spekulieren bevor es nicht gespräche
gibt
und dann haben wir noch eine wortmeldung
vom handelsblatt
sie hatten gerade gesagt ist eine
faszinierende kommunikation hätte
seitens der spd stattgefunden können sie
das vielleicht ein bisschen präzisieren
was genau für eine faszinierende
kommunikation das wesen es ziemlich auf
die interviews von herrn walter borjans
und von frau es kann vom heutigen tag
und wie ging nochmal hier in die erste
reihe direkt haben nico
herr lindner ist es vorstellbar dass sie
aus reihen der union einen anderen zum
kanzler wählen als den den die union zum
kanzler kandidaten aufgestellt hat oder
ist das etwas was wo sie sagen das ist
eigentlich prinzipiell ausgeschlossen
weil der ja gar nicht zur wahl stand
also wie man ihre frage auch beantworten
wollte es wäre immer falsch
und dann haben wir noch herr rösler
und herr weiland
einfacher kann ganz einfach zu
beantwortende frage wann beginnen die
gespräche mit dem
zeitnah
sie versteht ihre neugier aber bitte
sehen sie mir auch nach dass ich sie
nicht vollständig befriedigen will weil
es ist vieles im fluss dinge müssen
abgestimmt werden gremien werden
beteiligt vorbereitungen sind nötig und
da finde ich müssen alle so viel geduld
nach haben sie werden informiert werden
genug gelegenheiten dazu geben aber zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt in der jetzigen phase
wäre es töricht alles in der
öffentlichkeit oder über die
öffentlichkeit auszutauschen
so dann haben wir mit herrn will in
mailand und herrn böhm die letzten drei
fragen die ich sehe
christoph n tv.de herr lindner trifft es
zu medien haben darüber berichtet dass
sie gestern abend
beiden trinkend mit einer lasche
zusammengesessen haben oder vermuten sie
dass der wein an anderer stelle
geflossen ist und falls es noch eine
ampelkoalition möglichkeit geben sollte
ist es vorstellbar dass nach dem jamaica
aus von 20 17 die fdp jetzt auch zu
einer ampel nein sagt und falls amerika
nicht zustande kommt weil herr laschet
nicht mehr zur verfügung steht die fdp
dann am ende in der opposition landet
also ich sagte ich habe mit herrn
laschet herrn scholz und herrn beck
telefoniert
und zum zweiten
die fdp ist bereit verantwortung zu
übernehmen wir wollen auch gerne
beiträge leisten zu einem einem bündnis
dass unser land erneuert und eine
aufbruch organisiert aber wir sind
eigenständig
wir haben
kompromissbereitschaft jedoch auch
eigenem und überzeugungen die
auch berücksichtigt werden müssen bei
einer koalitionsbildung wenn sie keine
berücksichtigung fänden sprecherin
konjunktiv dann sind natürlich alle
optionen auf dem tisch aber
unsere absicht ist es ja dass wir dieses
land voranbringen können
herr weiland
ja ich habe noch mal eine frage zu ihm
jetzt von ihnen angekündigten gesprächen
mit den grünen
wird werden sie dort schon inhaltlich
darüber reden wo sie nah beieinander
sind und wo es dinge gibt die
möglicherweise erst in einer größeren
runde mit einem künftigen partner
besprochen werden können also sind das
spreche die auch schon in die substanz
gehen oder wird das dass gespräche die
erst mal nur wie es auch eine kollegin
fragte den rahmen abstecken wie viele
leute werden künftig daran teilnehmen
wie lange sollen die gespräche laufen
und so weiter und so fort es ist eine
neue situation dass zwei kleinere
partner eventuell darüber entscheiden
wer unter ihnen kanzler wird
an das ist gewiss nicht die absicht und
die formulierung die sie zuletzt gewählt
haben weil
jeder der eine regierung bild davon
profitiert wenn alle erfolgreich sind
und wenn sich jeder wiederfindet und
respekt gegenüber allen beteiligten die
grundlage ist deshalb ist die
formulierung die sie ausgangs ihrer
frage gewählt haben nicht unsere
es wird mit sicherheit darum gehen bei
wichtigen fragen zu prüfen wie die
gemeinsamen einschätzungen sind
aber das glaube ich ist auch es kein
staatsgeheimnis was ich was ich ihnen
sage dass werden sie sich vermutlich
gedacht haben dass man bei einem solchen
gespräch
absteckt wo sieht wer welche inhalte wo
gibt es welche gedanken
wo gibt es gemeinsamkeiten wo gibt es
unterschiede dass das nochmal in einem
vertraulichen rahmen miteinander
besprochen wird aber über diese
selbstverständlichkeit hinaus muss ich
noch mal um verständnis bitten dass ich
jetzt über einzelheiten nicht öffentlich
berichten mag
und dann haben wir abschließend noch
hier vorne in der ersten reihe hätten
die berliner sie haben mal gesagt ihnen
fehlt die fantasie für eine
ampelkoalition haben sie denn die
fantasie in gesprächen eine einigung zum
thema steuererhöhungen zu finden denn
sie schließen das kategorisch aus die
grünen würden viele ihrer projekte gerne
über eine solche finanzieren und wenn
sie noch ein oder zwei andere rote
linien nennen könnten wir das unter bahn
vielen dank für die einladung
es ist genauso wie wie vor der wahl hat
sich nichts verändert wenn man die
wahlprogramme von spd und grünen ansieht
dann fehlt mir die vorstellungskraft
welches inhaltliche angebot herr scholz
uns macht das auf begeisterung auch bei
herrn kühnert und bei fresken stößt so
dass die formulierung vor der wahl und
das ist die formulierung nach der wahl
bevor es gespräche gegeben hat und zum
anderen ja wohl was wir vor der wahl
gesagt haben gilt auch in der sache wir
haben zwei leitplanken der fdp wird es
keine höheren steuern geben mit der von
mir immer gemachten ausnahme google etc
und auf der anderen seite kein
aufweichen der schuldenbremse in unserer
verfassung das galt vor der wahl das
gilt als leitplanke auch nach der wahl
auf unserem bundesparteitag wenn sie die
gelegenheit hatten ihn zu verfolgen
hatte ich allerdings gesagt dass es
innerhalb der leitplanken natürlich
möglichkeiten gibt wo wir im zweifel
anderen auch gerne assistieren
finanzierungsmöglichkeiten für sinnvolle
ideen zu finden also etwa die freien
demokraten wir wollen ja auch etwas tun
für für kinder und für bildung aber
warum mit höheren steuern oder mit
höheren schulden wenn es auch innerhalb
des haushalts alternative
finanzierungsmöglichkeiten gibt
das war die letzte frage die ich gesehen
hab dann bedanken wir uns ganz herzlich
für ihre aufmerksamkeit und wünschen
einen schönen tag danke danke ihnen auf